et bon ça y est la nouvelle est tombée
stéphane bern en a marre de vivre à
paris et nous dit eh oui l'animateur
veut déménager dans sa résidence du
perche parce qu'apparemment à paribas il
suffoque en effet y trouverez que la
ville est devenue une vraie poubelle en
même temps ça doit pas être très simple
de se taper 4 heures de bouchons à
chaque fois qu'il veut sortir visiter un
château et en qualifiant paris le ville
poubelle ne s'en prendrait il pas
directement à anne hidalgo la pro du
vélib qui déteste les machines quand les
machines remplacent les humains ça va
pas pouvoir bref le résultat est le même
et sans appel stéphane des frais bien la
chronique en annonçant le départ ce sera
un voyage mouvementé
[Musique]
alors
alors allez les chéris
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr ça va très bien alors les gens
sur twitter les gens disent si rim doit
boire
des substances vous dit pas du tout et
c'est juste salle des quatre jours que
j'ai pas fait des missions que je lâche
tout ça les empêche non mais j'ai joué
100 ml soit pas auto week-end salle
micheu sortir entre à pas d'heure ouais
c'est vrai vous avez pas dit ce que vous
avez fait je serai donc calme toi
c'était la première fois que je rentre
au site a aboli vous étiez au toit
s'était pas tarder à lester tôt le matin
tout le monde oui moi c'est non merci
allez
vous mais qu'est ce que vous en fichiers
vous l'avez oui vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure va chier d'horreur
[Applaudissements]
jamais ce qu a dit stéphane bern paris
devenue une ville poubelle évidemment
elle n'arrête pas de chez nous
[Applaudissements]
cette
instance aura manuel valls
sans rire anciens amis de françois
hollande parce que vous avez eu les
propos d'eric et attention aux mots
l'eau last hit au 6 août donc si on
comprenait stéphane bern qui quittent
paris moi je comprends stéphane oui
voilà stéphane je le comprends oui et si
c'était de moi je suivrai stéphane bern
non c'est vrai que là ça devient
n'importe quoi à l'assemblée alors pour
se mettre en confiance collectivement
parce que c'est pas tout ça les travaux
civilitas du tout et non non non non
c'est pas pour ça c'est parce que c'est
les travaux c'est pour ça qu'ils par
stéphane bern et basque aujourd'hui dans
paris 1 vous croisez plus de rappels de
voitures c'est vrai c'est un truc de fou
ça veut dire que vous êtes
tranquillement en train de manger il ya
un rat limite maintenant vient s'asseoir
à table
c'est la politique hidalgo yara la clope
au bec hilal quétu probable
mervyn et mozzarella mon ami se plaît
mon ami leurs assauts pma disto blais
sera tête de ma mère mais pourquoi il ya
des rades partout en plus j'ai très mal
à elle en train de creuser parvient il
sort tels faits mais bien sûr elle fait
les travaux partout fait sans rigoler
donc les racks qui font en sorte qu'ils
aillent à l'hôtel de ville
mais sans rigoler c'est un truc de fou
une paris c'est devenu un truc de fou
mon frère est franchement mathieu
avant à l'époque chirac mois déjà mais
mes parents m'ont que j'ai par terre
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tu fais quoi bon
alors oui tu fais quoi mathieu non non
tu manges sur une table
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que voilà grâce à cette
émission vont bien l'évolution de la
société et c'est andré biyogo dit aux
gens qui nous regardent non mais sérieux
et paris aujourd'hui et qui valait à
géraldine qui la puissance et oui c'est
vrai que c'est dégueulasse circule mal
mais encore faut-il avoir la possibilité
de partir de paris mais la survie la
flexibilité la bei mais c'est moins cher
ailleurs le sont plus c'est hors de prix
avec maritime 17 capitale s'apprête
sérieux qui traitent des peuples seul
cap et déjà c'est robin c'était bien sûr
le vide oui oui mais voilà le temps pour
l'aller-retour apakan hidalgo se
présente à l'élection présidentielle je
ne vais pas que la france se dépeuple
3% on n'est pas bon il paraît qu'elle
hyper sympa samba tout le monde dit ça
qu'ils ont pas rencontré jamais de la
vie
j'ai croisé une première un jour d'un
film c'est hyper sympa hyper simple mais
c'est vrai qu'elle est sympa dans la vie
à mon pote sa penderie et dans le
travail était à côté de la plaque
n'est ce pas qu'à ça
non mais c'est vrai